[Música]
boa tarde pessoal do eu estou um pouco
nervosa né e depois da palestra de ana
paula fiquei sim
assim eu estou aqui pensando várias
coisas estão a subir antes enquanto eu
sei que estou passando o bastão para ela
acredito que sim porque esses dias pra
isso ele no braço
ela falou não tinha falei você se livra
essa é uma prática que saudade ela não é
não tinha falei meu deus
enfim me feminista já a gente socorro
mas em fina
vamos começar quente
segundo a onu o meio ambiente o plástico
é nosso maior desafio do século 21 sendo
responsável pela morte de mais de 100
mil animais marinhos a cada ano e outros
dados da onu meio ambiente mostram que
mais de 40% de todo o plástico já
produzido em 150 anos foi utilizado
apenas uma única vez antes do seu
descarte e apenas 9% de todo esse
plástico foi esse quadro e nesse meio
tempo eu estou falando aqui cerca de um
milhão de novas garrafas plásticas foram
produzidas e se nós pudéssemos
simplesmente como meu problema é eu vou
chamar que a natália da organização
porque eu trouxe vai ficar um pouco
difícil que mas vamos ver verdade chuva
aqui tem um pacotinho só com as bolinhas
e caramelo onde tem este filme
biodegradável envolvidos e pode
simplesmente com o mesmo também nos um
plástico no meio ambiente plástico é
porque não posso enfim quebrar a laje e
eu vou comer por favor ajude a tirar o
papel de salvi muito rápido na boca da
gente amido de milho então muita gente
me pergunta sobre o gosto é quando
encostei a gente sabe muito rápido
muito obrigada
ela então gente aqui foi por ser uma
esperança eu fiz com cocada e cofins com
a bola mas como era mais fácil e que
minha sobre a minha feminista é então as
embalagens ativas sul
elas nada mas é ela são alternativas
tecnológicas que irá permitir que o
plástico a embalagem em interaja com o
produto tá essa tradição ela pode ser
feita tanto diretamente ou indiretamente
mas o intuito no final mesmo que é
assegurar a sua qualidade e sua
segurança na sua vida de prateleira
aqui tem outros exemplos eu trouxe essa
imagem do instituto tecnológico de
alimentos do governo de são paulo onde
mostra o conceito das embalagens ativas
que abrange vários sistemas
então aqui tem uma cadeia bem enxuto
digamos de passagem na produção onde tem
o alimento ea bebida pode ser um
alimento sólido alimento líquido depois
de sua produção colheita entre a parte
da embalagem ipod
ai gente olha aí pode entrar
alternativos de atmosfera modificada
vai ter um absorvedor de carbono em dia
esse gênio entre outros
depois vai seguir essa trajetória normal
tá meio transporte
depois dependendo se a taxa chegar nós o
consumidor final
então eu trabalhei durante três anos na
linha de embalagens ativas antioxidantes
no meu primeiro ano eu fiz a avaliação
de diferentes bases poliméricas para o
desenvolvimento de filmes antioxidantes
incorporados com extrato de espécies
vegetais
o segundo grupo é basicamente a mesma
coisa só muda o polímero
já no último ano eu fiz após a aplicação
de filme à base de pva em alimentos
então esse primeiro ano é ano de testes
e é bem mais complicado alguém que
trabalhou ou trabalha com o laboratório
pesquisa essas coisas
é verdade sim então sempre tem fatores
externos internos que interferem na
nossa produção mas felizmente ao final
de um ano conseguir chegar na composição
com
neta e desenvolver esse filme é a
mensuração científica iniciou em 2014 e
orientadora a professora doutora
cristiane patrícia de oliveira
chegamos a três conclusões no primeiro
ano a gente percebeu que para utilizar
nos materiais naturais e também na sua
composição utilizar materiais com que o
limite se a gente poderia simplesmente
copeco filme né
e no segundo ano a gente percebeu que
para utilizar os materiais renováveis
amido de milho facó de batata que estou
usando a sua degradação era mais rápida
então amido de milho saco de batata
durava se uns três meses e também
trabalhamos com ipva pva ele é um
biodegradável mas ele é sintético então
não vai conferir essa alternativa de
comer 40 mil jogada foi muito rápida que
cerca de um ano já degradou então vocês
imaginam um plástico é embaixo um
sintético derivado do petróleo que leva
centenas de anos para se decompor 5%
comparados com ações que demoram três
meses quatro meses é tipo muito grande e
no último ano de iniciação científica em
eu percebi chegamos à conclusão que por
utilizarmos o antioxidante que no caso
foi o estado de cacau incorporado no
filme fazia o aumento do seu show fly
fishing é um termo utilizado na área de
alimentos que significa vida de
prateleira então simulamos na nossa casa
como se fosse a nossa casa mesmo
pegamos o filme incorporamos em
salsichas usando um controle que não
tinha de oxidantes e usando também com
antioxidantes e colocamos sobre geração
com o passar do tempo o tempo e fazendo
análises a gente percebeu que conde
oxidante aumentava a sua vida na
geladeira então imagine você tem um
alimento perecível que ir a sua casa
dura de três a quatro dias
aumentar o dobro de incrível
então eu trabalhei até 2016 nessa área
de nessa área de pesquisa
quais trabalhar eu percebi que eu não
queria seguir a área acadêmica muitas
pessoas me questionam isso tipo larissa
por que você tem pelo magistrado
falei gente eu preciso respirar um pouco
porque a universidade 62 eu eu eu eu
fiquei surtado assim eu tive crise de
ansiedade
se eu sair de casa com 18 anos fui morar
em uma cidade de cinco horas a mim então
tenho que viver lá sozinha e eu fui
cursar engenharia de alimentos na
universidade estadual do sudoeste da
bahia
então imagine uma pessoa com 18 anos
antissocial em morar sozinha
foi complicado eu lembro que quando eu
fui tentar minha bolsa como orientadora
eu não falava com ninguém
eu nunca estaria que hoje quatro anos
atrás cinco anos atrás porque eu
simplesmente não falava com ninguém eu
tive que ela não estar presente comigo
pra ir no laboratório falar que eu tinha
interesse na na bolsa vai ter assim
minha amiga me puxou e falou vamos
larissa senta aqui eu sentei defendi
minha professora pela mulher a um frango
que deu socorro aí amigo olha aqui é
larissa ela tem muito interesse
trabalhar no seu projecto na lista é
husan badran ou de um ruim eu consegui
trabalhar muito a minha cara mas enfim é
desenvolvemos um trabalho incrível
nesses três anos mas que infelizmente
agora eu não estou disposta a continuar
eu espero um dia voltar e como decidir
por outro caminho porque a engenharia de
alimentos é basicamente o que você faz
mestrado
você vai jogar ele ficar desempregado
porque basicamente isso
e aí sendo mulher claro é porque e então
decidiu que cara vamos jogar e vou criar
um canal porque o meu curso é fantástico
tem assuntos incríveis o tempo todo
então falei cara vou criar cada um tem
seu gosto por que minha sobrinha
responde isso pra mim contudo se ele vai
comer feijão não gosta tinha cada um tem
seu gosto enfim é eu comecei gravando
vídeos como hormone frango que acredito
que têm hormônios frango aqui várias
pessoas né então o vídeo é
contrário não tem vão lá assistir pra
vocês entenderem
hum e aí eu fui criando conteúdos não só
sobre a área de alimentos coisas
importantes com mulheres fantásticas e
onde habito aqui tem pessoas pessoas
famosas né
parecem pessoas também que não tem
visibilidade como minha orientadora que
ela é incrível a mulher negra que pode
sofrer racismo muito tempo e chegou onde
está hoje com doutorado
então acho muito importante falar sobre
isso e sobre os quesitos também como
perigo no nas praias na rua dome nação
tenham muito enfim é mais voltado para a
área de embalagens
nós sabemos que as embalagens plásticas
elas contribuíram bastante nos primeiros
sistemas de distribuição de alimentos na
mas hoje em dia elas não atendem mais
nossas necessidades
estamos sempre procurando por produtos
mais naturais
estamos sempre buscando alternativas
mais sustentáveis
um exemplo disso foi a proibição de uso
de calor dos plásticos quem estou aqui
no estado do rio de janeiro e que é algo
muito fantástico mas quem vale ressaltar
que gente não só pelo sta que os
materiais também são importantes fazer é
só eu para parar de consumir mesmo então
se vocês me permitem dar um conselho
para vocês
de tudo que aprendi nesses últimos anos
eu diria que nunca tarde pessoal para
mudar sua relação com o mundo e nem
consigo mesmo
recicle recicle tanto as suas ideias
quanto o sol o seu lixo que você e seus
amigos já muda seus hábitos desde sobre
as suas próprias ideias até o material
plástico que você consome mãe se nessa
chuva de 10
[Aplausos]